Elita battle angel takes place in a
post-apocalyptic world that might not be
filled with zombies or bizarre aliens
but a lot of crazy stuff still happens
there some of it however will sail right
over the heads of younger viewers here
are the things that only adults will
notice on any planet it seems unlikely
that a highly advanced cyborg would be
tossed out in the trash
well except for the version of Earth
that takes place in this anime and manga
adaptation even as is no limbs and
basically just a brain head and torso
Elita contains very rare technology that
can still sell for a lot of credits or
be a value to someone it's never
explained why she's thrown away so
casually and left out in the open when
she's found in the iron city scrapyard
by dr. IDO her face is easily visible
it's almost as if she was placed in that
spot intentionally perhaps someone from
the floating city of zalim did it in the
hopes of her being discovered and
restored to her prime form nonetheless
Center found state which is pretty
beat-up
she'd still be extremely valuable after
Edo brings Aleta to his lab and gives
her a new body she wakes up in a place
she's never been to before she doesn't
know where she is or how she got there
she doesn't even know her own name
basically her memory bank has been wiped
out and she's starting over as a 300
year old teenager for most adults it's
hard to think that a cyborg like Aleta
wouldn't be somewhat frightened she's
either really good at compartmentalizing
or just moves on fast while it can be
argued that she's simply a cyborg not to
mention a killing machine it's important
to mention that she has human emotions
she cries falls in love and perhaps most
human of all has empathy for a scrappy
little dog Aleta has every reason to be
freaked out but instead she's super
casual about her current state of
affairs or at least as casual as you can
be if you wake up in the midst of a
bustling dystopian city IDO has all of
the signs of an overbearing parent he
tells Aleta she needs to be home before
dark and not to trust anyone he also
tells her what she can and can't
do such as become a bounty hunter short
of grounding her he does his best to
control her every move
and if you go out during the day don't
wander too far from this neighbor okay
Oh promise I promise of course Aleta
still has the raw emotions of a teenager
and the strength of a kick-ass cyborg
so trying to discipline her could get a
little awkward eventually when IDO truly
understands how powerful Aleta really is
he allows her to try out for a deadly
sport called motor ball although Dad
mode kicks in again when she's getting
suited up he's adamant about her wearing
pads in a helmet despite the fact that
participants with helmets can still get
their heads knocked off Hugo and Aleta
are a young couple and young couples are
known to fall for each other fast that's
definitely the case in this movie Hugo
and Aleta go into major I love you mode
after what appears to be only a few days
in a couple kisses that's all well and
good and no one can blame these two for
trying to find some good in a world
that's consumed by so much chaos and
uncertainty taking it up a notch Aleta
quickly gets kind of creepy not creepy
in the sense that she calls Hugo
non-stop or questions where he is and
who he's with but creepy in the sense
that she literally takes her heart out
of her chest
and offers it to him as Aleta says it's
all or nothing with me
this is who I am and giving your heart
away so someone else can make his or her
dream come true is about as
all-or-nothing as it gets
bounty hunters no matter what universe
they're in have extremely dangerous
occupations and can easily be harmed or
worse yet swallowed by a giant toothy
creature in the desert despite the
dangers of the job in Alita battle angel
it's way too easy to become a licensed
bounty hunter or as they're called in
iron city hunter warriors it almost
seems like signing up to be a
post-apocalyptic uber driver ito who has
been around the block a few times
works as a hunter-warrior to make ends
meet but Aleta who looks very young and
has no experience simply walks into a
big building wearing a cool leather
jacket and acts like she's registering
for a class state your business
I'm here to register as a hunter-warrior
and just like that she becomes a
hunter-warrior on the spot the ease of
becoming a hunter-warrior is likely
because there's such a high demand for
them the people of zalim and especially
the film's evil mastermind nova want the
city policed and they don't seem to care
who does it as long as everyone stays in
line if one feels brave enough to hit
the streets and start bounty hunting
then he or she apparently can for a
post-apocalyptic world the general
population seems somewhat tame in iron
City no one tries to escape the
impoverished streets or rebel against
the elitist society in the sky while the
city is surrounded by a Hydra wall
everyone is content with staying within
its boundaries there appear to be other
places in the cyberpunk world that are
habitable for example the badlands is
flush with water and wilderness which
makes it look like a paradise meanwhile
the city is plagued with unfair social
structures endless violence and
power-hungry villains with grotesque
interests I want to rip you open to see
if you're ugly inside
like the others compared to the
alternative the Badlands look like a
reasonable place to start a new life
there's no one around and the security
forces of zalim don't appear to monitor
it Elita easily retrieves a suit from a
partially submerged battleship that
clearly hasn't been inspected the ship
is filled with alien technology and
according to Hugo has mostly been left
alone
maybe citizens have tried to escape and
failed maybe iron City is all they know
and a better option than exploring the
unknown who knows they might even like
it but the wilderness of the Badlands
seems like a solid place to call home
especially compared to the overcrowded
in hyper violent streets of iron City
and honestly who wants to go out for an
evening stroll and run into this guy
tomato flee
I can pinch your head off check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]